[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lori is
with us Lor's in Milwaukee Wisconsin Hi
liui how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up um so I
just started out listening listening
about a month ago because that is super
intimidating and so a quick question my
husband is in grad school and we have
quite a chunk of debt from it um but he
just accepted a job with a
$30,000 sign on bonus um that we get
next week even though he doesn't
graduate until August of
2024 and so we're not sure how we should
use it and we've kind of come up with
some options the first is to pay for the
next nine months of living in tuition
and not take out any more loans um the
second is to keep it and use it for
moving help or a possible down payment
for a house or three is to just pay off
some of our debt now um to get the
interest down and then take out loans to
pay for the rest of our tuition
the first thing you've got to do to get
out of debt is stop borrowing
more okay so option
one okay and uh so what's his graduate
degree in what's he gonna be doing he's
going to be a nurse
anesthetist fantastic okay and so how
much debt have you got we have 155 right
now okay and that includes his student
loans that is all student loans nothing
else okay good and he's going to be
making what
250 uh 210 starting good good almost
like I've done this before okay and um
yeah
so you're you been you currently make
what nothing because you're living on
student loans right right I do Nanny and
so I bring in $1,600 a month which just
pays for like utilities and if I were if
if what what does it cost you a month to
live right now our rent is
1,400 um so probably I'm trying to add
up like cell phone bills and stuff
probably around like 1,800 a month yeah
let's call it
3,000 okay okay I want you to live on
that when he's making
210 okay and you'll be debt free in a
year and would renting be the best
option right out of graduating you do
not need to buy a house you're
broke okay you're in Deb up to your
eyeballs you and you don't need to buy a
car and you don't need to go on vacation
you have
$155,000 you make
$210,000 when he passes his bars and
everything and and August goes to work
and the problem with people in that
world is that they make good money he
chose a fabulous career
field and they make good money and they
think that gives them permission to wait
forever to deal with this I'm telling
you to deal with it right now yeah
okay and to that end Lori quick question
is there a reason why you aren't working
full-time and making more money than
that I'm I'm a stay at home mom I just
have little little kids at home with me
that's all okay well I got you that's
that's awesome just wanted to make sure
I understood that situation because we'd
love to see you make more if you could
so 40,000 a Year 3,000 a month is 36,000
okay
40,000 from 210 is
170 minus
taxes you can just about pay this off in
a year you can come real close it'
probably be 14 months but you're going
to live like you're living now not like
you've been dreaming of living when your
husband has the big-time job he's a
nurse anesthesist no he's a broke NSE
nurse
anesthesist yeah that's what you need to
think about CU all the people graduating
with him are getting ready to do really
stupid things while they still are
sitting on 200 and student loan
debt okay I promise you if you go if you
go with that herd you're going to go
over the cliff with that
herd right yeah which is why I just
started listening to you because I was
like this is super intimidating and so
didn't know how to tackle it and so what
would our monthly payment look like then
well to try to get that done if you did
155 uh in 10 months it'd be 15,000 a
month right oh my gosh okay that that
just simple math if you do it in 20
months it's going to be 7,000 a month
you're going to do somewhere between
there 12,000 A month's 144 a
year okay and you said try to stay at
3,000 a month for living and everything
what you're spending now why do you need
to go
up true true yeah I mean matter of fact
we increased you said 1,800 I went to
3,000 I almost doubled your
budget that is true I mean it's all
kinds of luxurious compared to where you
are now cuz here's the thing once you're
living on 70,000 a year it's really hard
to live on
36 but if you're living on 30 and you
get to live on 36 you feel like you got
a
raise yeah my parents always tell me
don't go backwards once you go forward
it's it's a hard step to take this is
the that's why this is the time to do it
yep because if you if you kick the can
down the road you go oh we're going to
go ahead and buy a house and we're going
to let this student loan sit over here
and act like it's not a monster in the
closet by the time you do all that and
then you try to cut your lifestyle down
after you've gotten used to the nice
cushy lifestyle it's a lot harder than
it is right now for
you okay cuz right now while you're used
to living on nothing keep living like a
college student right right yeah I could
do little enough I'm telling you in 14
months y'all could be free forever think
about it Lori I mean you got the rest of
your life to make $250,000 a year and
you don't have a payment in the world
you know how fast I mean think about it
you could save $100,000 a year for three
years and pay cash for a $300,000
house that's W so don't when we talked
about putting a little aside for a down
payment ignore that completely inj just
do student debt yes ignore completely
you're going to get there my point is
when you have all this money and no
payments in the world you can do
anything you want to do you're gonna be
in great shape please do this please
please please